alright guys bangbang super-excited have
Jameson lop here to celebrate the
bitcoin having the third having the
historic moment calls for none other
than then one of my favorite people in
Bitcoin and and an old gene is owned
right so thanks for doing this man happy
having day yeah exactly for those that
don't know you let's just start with
your background and kind of what you did
before you got into Bitcoin and then
we'll get into those early days yeah I'm
a computer scientist by trade spent the
first decade of my career actually
working for an online marketing company
doing large-scale cloud computing data
analytics and actually stripping
people's privacy away basically the
antithesis of what I try to promote
these days so you know that provided
some interesting technical challenges
but I was never really that interested
in the business and it just happened to
come across the Bitcoin white paper a
number of years ago and once I read it I
realized it was really fascinating from
a computer science standpoint from an
economic standpoint and just the idea of
money as an open collaborative project
was very interesting to me so started
doing some side projects in the Bitcoin
space and after a couple of years
realized there was enough VC money that
I could just get paid to continue
working on Bitcoin full-time so I've
been doing Bitcoin security for five
years now both at an enterprise setting
with bit go and for the past couple of
years for individuals at Casa yeah and
so I guess let's go back to the first
time you read the Bitcoin white paper
like how did you come across it and what
was your initial thought were you just
immediately like hey this is the future
or were you skeptical how did that go
down no you know there's a longer story
there and it's the same thing that we
hear with a lot of people is I'll never
actually remember the first time I heard
about Bitcoin because I dismissed it
three or four times before I actually
read about
and realized what an innovative new
solution this was because really I had
never thought about money before I had
never thought about who controls these
systems and it wasn't until probably the
third or fourth time I think it was a
slash dot article that I finally clicked
on that link I finally read the white
paper and it was only like eight or nine
pages it's it's not as difficult a
technical read as most white papers are
so I would definitely recommend everyone
read it but when I read that I realized
you know this was solving a problem that
I had never even thought about before
and it was just really interesting I
felt like this had the potential to be
revolutionary though of course this was
the very early days there was a lot of
work that needed to be done and so that
was just the beginning of my journey and
we're still in the early days and
there's still a lot of work to be done
for sure and then what kind of gave you
the confidence right there's a lot of
people who will go read the white paper
or they'll talk to a friend and it's
like hey this is interesting but it's
super speculative and maybe I want to
you know take kind of 1% of all the
money that I have and I'll see what it's
about and put a little money in you me
many others have I think become much
larger believers than that and made kind
of a bigger financial bet on that
actually being the future what gave you
the confidence of that in the early days
and then kind of how did you think about
moving from a fiat denominated majority
world to a Bitcoin world yeah I mean it
was a long process you know when I first
got into it I only put a little bit of
money and just because I figured I need
to actually have some in order to play
with it in order to better understand
how it works
it wasn't until two or three years later
after I had multiple projects and I had
been using it on a regular basis that I
actually decided that this was something
that even though it was risky I actually
wanted to make a large financial
commitment and that's when I went to the
trouble of figuring out how to turn my
retirement money into a self-directed ir
so that I could hold a real Bitcoin in a
tax-advantaged account and you know that
ended up it was it was a crazy idea at
the time you know this was like right
after a mount GOx crash and everybody
was telling me how insane I was and it
ended up being a good financial bet but
really my understanding of the system
has continued to evolve every year you
know as new things happen and every new
thing that happens every event that
Bitcoin overcomes just strengthens my
belief in the resilience of the system
and ultimately it's less about the
technical aspects and more about the the
human underpinning of all of the people
like myself who were just frankly not
going to give up on this we're not going
to let it die and that's kind of the
mantra that I've come to believe is that
you know Bitcoin can't fail unless there
is a consensus amongst all of us to
allow it to fail yeah it's um it's this
nuanced version I think a lot of people
when they see a product or service they
evaluate the technical merits they
evaluate the cash flow can I all you
everything you would do with a
traditional product money in general is
very different and it goes back to this
idea that money is a belief system right
I don't care what the technological and
under pending is what whether it's the
US dollar or any other currency in the
world it is ultimately a belief system
and when you get that belief the only
way to have that money fail is when
people stop believing right we see that
the fiat world all the time we're
hyperinflation that kind of breaks the
belief of people that it's a store of
value and and it fails it sounds like
you're saying the same thing here is
just with a digital currency called
Bitcoin rather than any other currency
in the world yeah it's great though the
having event that's happening today
while I don't believe that in and of
itself this is a major economic or
financial catalyst what it is is
evidence that the rules of the network
of the protocol are known by everyone
cannot be manipulated by anyone
we'll continue to be predictable and
provide a robust foundation that we can
build other things on top of yeah now
you have a I think a number of nuanced
views around Bitcoin around privacy and
kind of a digital world
some of that my understanding is just
ethos driven right you like you just
believe these things some of it though
comes from personal experience one of
those things is the now-infamous
swatting story maybe just kind of for
those that don't know that story quickly
tell what happened there and then we can
get into some of the things that you've
done in your life and lifestyle to
change and kind of prevent yourself from
this weird digital world that's coming
yeah you know one of the more insane
things about this space is how quickly
it grows and how a dynamic it is how how
many things change both from a security
perspective and it is sort of day-to-day
I guess level of interest and people who
are paying attention to you and it was
really was the attention and it was the
the mania of the 2017 hype that
drastically changed my life not really
so much from the monetary standpoint but
more of just going from being some
nobody software coder who randomly
blathers about libertarian stuff and
cryptocurrency on Twitter to a guy who
has you know six figures of followers on
Twitter and that is really no different
from what happens to people who become
overnight like viral sensations or win
the lottery or whatever it's just that
you're your threat profile can change so
quickly in this space and that may be
because you're outspoken on social media
and have a viral effect there it may be
because you know your wealth go
10 X or 50 X overnight and people knew
about that because you had been talking
about it and so all of a sudden I start
getting attacked in ways that I haven't
before and and the thing about swatting
it only takes one person who knows how
to make an anonymous phone call and do
some simple online searches to find your
physical location to basically target
you and send you no nation state-level
attackers to your door who are ready to
commit violence and and so that's what
happened to me
I basically caught the attention of the
wrong person and they decided that I had
been in Bitcoin for a while and I could
probably be extorted for Bitcoin and
that if they started attacking me in
different ways that they could scare me
enough to try to buy them off and that
didn't quite work in fact I the they
were extorting me for about $50,000 and
I ended up spending about that much to
completely burn down my life and start
it all over again from a privacy
perspective so it was definitely a
learning experience I've written a lot
about it and I've discovered how
difficult it really is to live on the
edge of extreme privacy and the odd
thing is that at least in America this
is feasible if you have the time and
money but in many other countries it's
just not legally possible to protect
yourself in the way that you can with
various like legal entities in the
United States yeah and you know when you
first told me the swatting story I think
part of what was so scary about it is
when you put yourself in the perspective
of the police right when when they're
actually showing up they have no clue
what's going on they have no context all
they know is they got this anonymous
call there's dangerous situation and you
actually weren't home if I remember
correctly and so you kind of showed up
and was like hey what's going on which
you know I'm sure confuse them just as
much as as them already kind of being in
this heightened state of panic and so
ultimately just scary right yeah that
was the only thing that went
was that whenever I make like public
comments about things that might somehow
be tied to my location I usually do so
in a delayed fashion and so my best
guess is that that morning I got up I
went to the gym and when I was at the
gym I made a tweet about waking up and
having to deal with stuff with the
current drama on Twitter and it was
within 30 minutes of that tweet the SWAT
team showed up at my house as I was
trying to come back into my neighborhood
so I couldn't get into my own
neighborhood because they had cordoned
it all off and it took a few minutes to
figure out that they were looking for me
I was the armed assailant that they were
trying to track down so I was lucky that
you know my local police department had
done enough research that they realized
that the phone call was not coming from
my house or even from my state so they
somewhat knew that it was possibly a
fake but of course like you said they
have to treat every situation like it's
life or death and that is one of the
crazy things about this asymmetric
attack where someone can spend a few
dollars to make an anonymous phone call
and get a hundred thousand dollars worth
of taxpayer resources pointed at an
arbitrary target that's just the crazy
thing about this space in general is how
asymmetric some of the attacks and
defenses are but I'm also very bullish
on it because I believe with the
technology applying it correctly we can
actually give people a level of security
that they wouldn't ever be able to
afford before for their assets yeah and
so obviously that event was was pretty
material and you know one that just a
scary experience but two it puts you on
this path to completely you know change
your life in the way that you interacted
both digitally and then also with
various assets or communication maybe
talk a little bit about kind of what
that paths been like and then describe
like what your life looks like now
compared to them
yes so I basically had to figure out you
know what are all of the different
trails of data that you leave laying
around as you're going about your normal
life setting up various accounts and
services buying things and essentially I
had to figure out how do I plug all of
these data leaks because this is the
particularly challenging thing about
privacy is you know keeping the data
from getting to people that you don't
want it to and so essentially I had to
figure out how to create shields how to
create proxies and I did this in a
variety of different ways I created
technical proxies you know VPNs and tor
for all of my internet traffic
I created legal proxies through
attorneys through trusts through
anonymous LLC's that did not have my
name listed on them as the owner and
then I use proxies for a number of
different things like receiving and
sending physical goods you know I have
other mailboxes set up around the
country to receive physical mail and
whenever possible use third-party people
you know hired proxies to avoid having
to do any sort of like face-to-face
interaction with people who would
otherwise potentially ask for my real
identity so it's it makes your life a
lot complicated that's for sure and it's
not it's not free from either a time or
a money perspective you if I remember
correctly hired like a private
investigator to basically double check
your work if you will what was that like
yeah first of all it took me a while to
find what I was looking for you know
normally you hire pis to go after other
people who owe you money or somehow it
harmed you and so it was pretty rare you
know to ask someone to find yourself but
it worked out pretty well and it allowed
me to find
a couple of leaks which you know
resulted in me taking more drastic
action
the most drastic actually being around
my driver license and having to set up
another sort of decoy residence and
really like the DMV is one of the most
aggressive institutions in America when
it comes to like verifying your
information so in order to make sure
that my real regular home address didn't
show up anywhere I had to make sure I
had a decoy somewhere else that is a
real place and of course it's not cheap
to do that yeah I feel like when you get
deeper and deeper down this rabbit hole
the more you realize there's a trade-off
between privacy and convenience after
everything you went through is that the
biggest hurdle for other people to do
this just the convenience and kind of
the capital needed or is it a knowledge
gap like why doesn't everyone go do this
yeah so it adds friction to many points
of your daily life to do this before I
did it there wasn't even really a great
singular resource that covered all the
different aspects of your life as of
today about a year after I went through
all this this an anonymous privacy
expert called Michael basil came out
with a book called I think the ultimate
guide to privacy it's on Amazon highly
recommend it has everything that I did
and more so it's certainly possible but
once again that's like a three or four
hundred page book with a lot of
step-by-step instructions for what you
need to go through now the initial
onboarding part if your first of all you
have to be willing to pretty much
completely burn down your life sever all
ties with your current physical
addresses and start over again and so
you'll easily spend several months doing
that but once you get through that I
would say the ongoing maintenance is not
nearly as bad and where do you feel like
the greatest friction is on a day to day
basis is it receiving mail is it not
going to see people in person like where
is that obstacle yeah I mean it comes
down to how far you really want to take
it so for me I moved to a different
location where no one knew who I was and
I actually created an alias so no one
around here knows my real name no one
knows what I do I that's mainly because
I wanted to push it to the extreme just
to see if it would work you know see if
I would be able to to hide myself in
that way but there are different levels
of this right you don't need to go to
the extreme that I did I think that most
people would be far better off if they
simply do a weekend of improving their
technical privacy and figuring out how
to set up ad blockers and VPNs and just
obscuring their day-to-day web traffic
you know now this brings us to the
question of privacy and kind of
sovereignty around Bitcoin you are
probably one of the biggest proponents
of this mostly because of the other
things you've done in your life let's
just start from a high level like what
does it mean to have financial privacy
and mean to have financial sovereignty
yeah they kind of go hand in hand you
know if you want to be sovereign you
want to be able to make payments send
money without having to ask permission
then that means you can't have any
middlemen that are sitting in there
watching everything that you do and and
then potentially blocking what you're
doing the privacy aspect I mean privacy
and security are both both very
complicated things to quantify because
there's a million different variables
and you have to usually start at the
beginning and say well what is your
threat model what are you trying to
protect yourself against because that's
how you then decide what's precautions
you really need to take the the big
problem you know with the communication
age and where we are today with the
internet is that people on a regular
basis pretty much every day are sending
their personal and in many cases pride
at financial information to a number of
different third parties and so over time
that just keeps building up and building
up and each time you give sensitive
information to a third party you're
hoping and trusting that they will keep
that secure so over years and years that
you've interacted with thousands or tens
of thousands of different third parties
then the likelihood that one of them is
going to get hacked is going to leak
that information basically you know
approaches 100 100 percent and so that
is why that's the hard part is
preventing that information from leaking
in the first place and why I've gone to
the extreme of having you know proxy
fake information that I give to all of
these third parties instead and you know
you don't have to go to the extreme of
setting up all these different legal
entities there are services out there
like privacy calm or you can create
unique throwaway debit cards that give
you as an extra layer of shielding
between your regular bank account and
the merchants for example but you know
these are all things that are covered in
the resources yeah and so I guess as
part of this when people hear you say
fake information how much of this is
hard to do but legal versus not legal
but worth the privacy right and and
legal really what I'm trying to get at
is to have you clarify how much of this
can be done by a regular individual
who's not worried about or who has no
desire to even come close to kind of
skirting the law if you will versus like
hey I literally just put a fake address
on you know piece of on a document and
if they ever found out that I would get
in trouble yeah you know this is
probably one of the most unnerving
aspects of it is you know people are
generally they want to be honest they
don't want to get in trouble for lying
and I think that it's actually covered
pretty well in the privacy book that I
mentioned where at least in America and
you
I'm not a lawyer so don't you check with
your own attorney again I've spent a lot
of time and money on attorneys myself
with all of this at least in America if
you're not signing a legal contract or a
legal document or you're not engaging in
some sort of activity with a government
agency then you can absolutely lie about
your name and your identity like it's
not a crime to give a false name or
information unless it's to you know
certain official authorities or you know
something in the legal sense but to a
merchant it is completely valid to give
a fake name and an address that may not
even exist and in some cases if you get
to the extreme of all of this and you
think you've improved your privacy
sufficiently then like the final step is
actually disinformation is actually
putting your real name and many fake
addresses out into the internet and
hoping that they get sucked up by all of
these information engines to then create
a smokescreen that makes it almost
impossible for someone to figure out you
know what is the real information the
alias that you're using don't tell me
what it is obviously but I would love to
know is it a ridiculous name or is it a
very common name and the reason being
I've got to imagine that you're having
some fun with some of this and and
there's this element of there it's
serious but also there's a little bit of
a game aspect to it too right yeah I
know I know very common and and that's
another thing about you know aliases is
you want to pick one that will not
create any suspicions and needs to be
common based upon your local area and
customs and culture and your own
background so no one know McLovin type
name nope alright let's get into the
custody so obviously maybe talk a little
bit just about not your keys not your
coin what that means to you have been
get into a cos you're in a casa
yeah so you know bitcoin is an asset of
a forum that we've never really seen
before it has properties of many
different assets you could say it's some
sort of hybrid of all of these things
but it definitely seems to be unique in
the specific set of properties that it
has
now one of those properties is that it
is a it is a custody like asset it's a
hard asset that you yourself can control
similar to physical things like gold
precious metals diamonds what-have-you
it happens to also have these other
asset attributes that are mainly because
it has digital properties so you know
you can send it for example over the
internet at practically the speed of
light but the ownership asset is a very
important attribute for people to
understand because of the way that all
these other digital online accounts work
today and most people are they're used
to just going to their bank or PayPal or
some other third-party financial service
and logging in and doing whatever they
need there and and it's done but if
you're for example going to an exchange
or some other provider that is a like
Bitcoin service and you're just logging
in and instructing them to do things
then what you've done is you've entered
into a bank like relationship where
you're not actually directly controlling
that money you're not actually
controlling that Bitcoin you're
instructing a third party who actually
controls it - please do these things on
your behalf so essentially you don't own
Bitcoin from a control standpoint you
own io u--'s - Bitcoin that someone else
actually controls and I think it's
important for people to understand this
distinction because of the way that the
system itself operates you know we've
created financial infrastructure over
the past hundred years that has resulted
in a fairly small number of large
institutions essentially controlling
everything we've got these
intermediaries that are are watching all
of our transactions and you know they're
doing it for our own good rights they're
they're trying to protect us from fraud
they're trying to protect illegal
activity from happening to people but
ultimately it's a double-edged sword is
that they may also end up harming people
by blocking various transactions that
are not actually causing harm and you
know this is where you get into the
legal gray areas for example around like
the sex industry or the legal cannabis
industry etc etc there's plenty of other
examples but one of the biggest features
of Bitcoin is censorship resistance it
is the removal of intermediaries who can
block you there's a famous quote I think
it's generally that bitcoin is for the
payments that they don't want you to
make and you know this is I think in the
history of Bitcoin that the first thing
that really proved its censorship
resistance was the rise of Silk Road and
darknet markets and while that is as of
today a very small fraction of the
crypto economy they still continue to
exist and you can't stop people from
making these payments regardless of
whether or not a government agrees with
it or not
and so if we want Bitcoin to really
fulfill that promise if we want people
to be able to reduce the power of what
these intermediaries can do then we need
to take the power away from them and you
know pull it into the hands of the
individuals and so that's why I want to
continue to see more people you know
remove their coins from exchanges and
and hold their own private keys but you
know this it it makes a lot of people
nervous because they've never done
anything like it before there's a
million different pitfalls of ways that
people can
screw up and potentially lose their
money and so this is why for the past
five years I've I've continued to be
focused on the same boring old thing
which is just private key management is
this fundamental usability layer that I
think we need to continue working on in
the space and it's what led me to found
a casa a couple of years ago and I think
we've done a great job making strides
forward in there and unfortunately it's
mainly due to very hard lessons that we
and others have learned over the years
of cataloging everything that you might
accidentally do wrong and every way that
you might actually accidentally be
tricked into giving your your keys your
money to someone else yeah and so let me
talk a little bit about you know really
the mission behind Casa and then
describe some of the products you guys
have built so I think a lot of people
think of it as it's a company that has a
product but you guys actually have
multiple products that serve different
use cases yeah I mean our mantra all
along has been that we are a personal
sovereignty company we are trying to
build software that helps people help
themselves one of our our employees it
recently started trying to propagate a
new thing where he wants us to say at
Casa or all about holding your hands not
holding your keys so you know we are
non-custodial we do hold one out of a
set of keys for emergency recovery
backup purposes and that is mainly to to
help people who might shoot themselves
in the foot be able to recover from what
could otherwise be a catastrophic
scenario but our primary thing that
we've been focused on for the past
couple of years is self custody it's how
do we take this enormous problem space
of everything that could possibly go
wrong if you are controlling your own
private keys and build a user enter
face you know abstraction layer on top
of it that makes it as easy to use as a
mobile app you know like Facebook or
whatever so that's really what we've
built is we've built a mobile app that
is very easy to follow the instructions
of how to set up and manage your keys
and we've gotten rid of complex things
like having to actually take cede
phrases and write them down and figure
out how to secure them against physical
loss and physical theft and instead
we're leveraging other technology that
other companies have built these
hardware devices like treszura ledger
cold cart and so on to actually maintain
the integrity of those keys but really
the most important thing that we've done
is we've made multi-sig easier and what
is multi-sig it basically means that in
order to send your money you have to
have multiple signatures you know
multiple authorizations with
cryptographic attestation that it's okay
to send this money and this is part of
the Bitcoin protocol very standard thing
we're not rolling our own crazy setup or
anything and by having use multiple
devices that are holding the multiple
keys and then distributing those around
different geographic areas it gives you
this level of robustness that eliminates
every single point of failure so I
actually truly believe that with you
know the advent of cryptography and
these devices and a properly robust
architected set up you can actually do
far better than what Bitcoin has
promised for many years which is to be
your own bank I actually believe we can
move beyond that we can be better than
our own bank because we can create
setups that are more distributed and not
prune to single points of failure like a
physical bank would be and so what a lot
of people here secure your own keys
like these I think are scary kind of
what appear to be technical terminology
and they're thinking oh my god I'm gonna
have to go read like this technical
guide book and there's me 500 pages and
I'm not technical so I just can't figure
it out you guys obviously have built
something that makes that much easier
but maybe just those that don't
understand what exactly is a key right
and kind of how does that play into this
because I think they hear a lot they see
MCE or not your keys not your coin but
it's not a physical key obviously so
maybe kind of explain that a little bit
as well yeah you know it's it's not a
physical key but we've actually found
that by taking these digital keys and
getting rid of the need for people to
actually manage the raw information
those seed phrases that are used to
create all the cryptographic keys we
actually pull it back into the physical
realm we say okay you're just keeping
your keys on this device and you can
very easily visualize you know where is
this device we actually show you know a
visualization in the app that says you
know this is your whole set of devices
and and we give you reminders you know
make sure you check on this one and you
perform an integrity check so that we
know everything's going well but
ultimately the best way to think about
Bitcoin is that you're
just accessing this ledger with
everybody's money on it rather when
you're creating a Bitcoin transaction
you are creating inputs where your crib
your cryptographically signing proof
that you own you know the values in the
ledger and then you're sending them to
outputs and the outputs they have
scripts that are essentially locking
them it says these are the conditions
required in order for the money and in
this particular Bitcoin structure to be
spent and there's a million different
things that you can do with the
programming language but what we're
doing is very simple which is we're
creating a script that says these are
the three different keys that are
allowed to sign to spend from this
particular Bitcoin structure and you
need two of them in order for the
network to accept it
or we also have a three out of five or a
three out of six it really depends on
your level of security and so then it
becomes a lot easier for us to say okay
we know that these are the devices that
are necessary to co-sign a transaction
now we just need to figure out how are
we going to distribute these devices in
order to have the best you know physical
redundancy in security where do you go
from here right it's I think a lot of
people would say hey it's really cool
you guys have built so far when you look
out over the next 1 to 5 years like what
else do you guys have ambitions to build
and kind of what do you think is
possible so one thing that I think not
many people in the space have thought
through yet is inheritance and we've
spent nearly a year building out a full
inheritance product and plan that
actually works within the regular estate
planning process so you don't have to
roll your own that was actually
something that I did back and I think
2015 or 2016 I went through creating a
last will and testament even though I
had no one really to leave it to is I
just wanted to make sure
my coins didn't disappear and stay
locked up forever so there's a lot of
complications around that other even
game theory for example ultimately we
want to see Bitcoin continue to be used
by more and more people so you know we
have dabbled a bit with lightning
Network where I'm sure gonna see more
types of payment technology come into
play who knows what may end up being
built on a variety of side chains for
example and how how can we plug those
and but for today and we've found that
like the most important aspect to work
on is helping people secure large
amounts of wealth you know if they've
ended up with a significant portion of
their net worth in Bitcoin how can we
help protect that because if everybody
is losing their money left and right
then that is gonna erode confidence
perhaps not in the fundamental protocol
but in the ability for the system itself
to gain mass adoption and we are also in
a way competing against this looming
threat of the centralized providers
where I know a lot of people are leaving
their money on their exchanges simply
because they feel like it's better to
have it with a team of experts than to
take on that responsibility for
themselves I think that this is a larger
issue of us needing to start to you know
move society in the direction of
self-reliance and self responsibility
but in order to do that we need to lower
the bar we can't require people to spend
weeks or months learning all this
technical jargon and thinking through
all the edge cases and the security
setup so there's still plenty to do
there hopefully we don't have to learn
many more hard lessons unfortunately I
think that as long as large amounts of
Bitcoin are stored with third parties
there will be more hard lessons to be
learned
yeah it's um it's really interesting I
think because there's an ethos driven
kind of psychological component to this
and then there's actually executing it
right and you guys have done a really
good job of putting that position one of
the questions that I got from people
when I asked on Twitter before we did
this was what is something that you
believed in the early days that you have
softened your stance on so something
that you believed you know very strongly
and now either maybe have changed your
mind or or softened your stance well I
was and many people often forget this
but I was actually a big blocker back in
the day I I thought that you know one of
the premises of Bitcoin should be that
transactions should be cheap and it
wasn't until I actually started working
in the space and started having to run a
lot of Bitcoin nodes that were then
being used by infrastructure that I
realized it's not just about the current
transaction throughput it is about the
aggregate you know amount of data that
the entire blockchain is storing and if
you allow that to accelerate then it
becomes you know geometrically if not
exponentially more difficult for a
newcomer to come in and validate the
entire history and be able to set up
their own node and infrastructure so one
of the the issues that I ended up having
was with people who were only focused on
you know what is the hardware that is
capable with you know keeping up with
the current volume of transactionally
how many transactions per second can we
do that the hardware can keep up with
basically nobody was ever thinking about
well yeah but how long does it take to
sink from scratch and so you know that's
actually one of the projects that I do
on an annual basis is I resync a whole
bunch of nodes not only for Bitcoin but
also for other popular networks just to
compare to see like which ones are
becoming easier to audit and which ones
are becoming more difficult to audit
speaking of other chains there was I
think every [ __ ] corner and every
intellectually honest person in the
comments of my question asking we know
that he's very bullish and has a
deep-seated belief in Bitcoin is there
any other projects in the space that
either one you're curious about think
you're interesting or maybe even or kind
of a big believer yeah so I am I'm
interested in anything that promises
better privacy so I'm interested in
things like Manero Z cash grin you know
any insanely out there new like
cryptographic primitives that people are
playing around with these are often far
too experimental for us to imagine them
being brought onto Bitcoin anytime soon
but I would say that the thing that I
find least interesting are the the
various networks that claim to be like
infinitely scalable with free
transactions I think that that is not
being intellectually honest because
someone has to pay for it ultimately
it's the infrastructure providers
ultimately you end up you know
centralizing around a smaller and
smaller number of them I think a good
example of that would probably be a OS
which I believe only has like a few
dozen validators and I actually tried to
set up an EOS validate or just to see
and like it was too difficult even for
my beefy machine so it's interesting to
see the trade-offs that that certain
people are willing to make and you know
even if you only have a few dozen nodes
or whatever on the network you know you
can run it it'll it'll probably be fine
but the the trade-offs are not something
that I think the majority of people are
going to be willing to accept for sure
what do you think the biggest risk to
Bitcoin adoption is well that has been
an easy one for a long time and it's
just simple apathy
[Music]
this is where it gets really complicated
because there's such a diversity of
people out there and I actually think
that well I might be changing my mind a
little bit because of the current macro
environment but for a long time I felt
like trying to sell first world citizens
on the idea of Bitcoin it was almost a
lost cause unless they were hardcore
libertarian or Austrian you know
economics follower because the the
current financial system works pretty
well for most people in their own
perspective now people with different
perspectives people in countries with
hyperinflations you don't even have to
sell them on Bitcoin at all you just
tell them you know the supply is capped
at 21 million and they're sold at that
point because they understand they've
had to live through it now the real
question which I find interesting to be
happening you know right during this
having period is how many people in the
first world countries start to wake up
and realize that you know their wealth
is actually being stolen from them a
little little by little year-over-year
and eventually over their lifetime it'll
add up to be a significant fraction of
value that has been taken from them and
I would say an even more subversive way
than taxation is it's like a form of
Taxation that is very difficult for
people to even detect because it happens
over a long period of time it I've said
a bunch of times before that the
financial system is based on 50% or more
not understand how money works right
right it's very much a you can call it a
secret right you can call it whatever
you want but ultimately not only is
taxation but it's taxation without
people even realizing right and actually
people get hit the hardest by it but
people who live in cash definitely don't
understand that right
what um you're a big gun nut
which I appreciate having grown up in
North Carolina what is your favorite gun
and why um well my favorite one that I
own which i think is quite versatile and
also my recommendation for home defense
is a suppressed 45 caliber Kriss vector
with an extended 30 round magazine this
is subsonic rounds with the suppressor
on there it's great for home defense
because you aren't going to deafen
yourself and potentially create an even
worse situation if you're not able to
tell you know where attackers are in
your house it was actually funny story I
bought it on the recommendation of John
McAfee bodyguard so I was hanging out
with McAfee a few years ago on a sort of
business-related venture and I was
shooting the [ __ ] with his bodyguard for
a while and all and we started talking
guns and you know after 20 minutes of
talking guns he's like oh man you got to
get a Kriss vector and so I did and I
was some of the best firearm advice ever
sees how often do you go practice are
you somebody who who does a lot of
drills and goes to shoot quite a bit or
not so much not as often as I've wanted
to lately you know running a company
makes it a lot harder and and in fact
the weird thing is I've gotten into
virtual reality over the past couple of
years and even though it's not quite the
same experience it's so much more
convenient for me to walk over one room
and pull up a gun range and virtual
reality you know I don't have to pack up
all my guns and ammo left them over to
arrange fire everything and then come
back and disassemble everything and
clean it so you know I really only get
to do that every few months at this
point it's also much cheaper to go do it
in virtual reality right for sure what
is your thoughts around the China
hash rate there's a lot of detractors
that would say hey there's so much hash
rate of Bitcoin that's in China how do
you kind of think through that yeah I
mean it's not optimal if we're thinking
about nation-state level attacks but
even within China the actual mining
farms are highly distributed and my
understanding is a number of them are
you know really like out in the middle
of nowhere like jungle locations you
know basically directly plugged into a
hydroelectric dam so it would be an
interesting thought experiment to think
through you know how much resources
would really have to be committed by the
Chinese government in order to go in and
take these things over and use them for
malicious purpose and you know if they
did and they would then need to do so at
their own detriment
you know the whole point of the
incentives around mining is that it's
more profitable to go along with the
network and get paid by the network than
it is to attack the network but you know
assume China has infinite money and for
whatever reason they need to kill
Bitcoin the worst that they could really
do is either double spend the money that
they already have in Bitcoin or simply
perform a denial of service attack where
they stop confirming transactions and
then reorganize away any blocks from
other miners who do confirm transactions
so with either one of those it would be
apparent to the rest of us within you
know a matter of a few blocks and and so
there would be essentially an emergency
situation you know flag would go up
amongst a lot of people like myself and
we would come together and we would have
to analyze the situation and if we
determined that it looked like it was a
you know Chinese nation state led attack
that was actually going against the
incentives of the network then we would
need to figure out you know what is the
best way to respond to this
is it something that we believe would be
able to go on indefinitely or should we
wait it out
or should we propose some sort of code
change that essentially neuters the
existing hashing hardware yeah
it's crazy to go down that game theory
route we don't have time to do that
today but I could talk to you about that
for days and days one of the the
questions that I got that I thought was
really interesting was what is your
suggestion or working point people who
they bought crypto on a kyc AML exchange
they've now moved that off into a
hardware wallet or casas device but they
would like to try to reinstate some of
that privacy what's the best thing that
they can look at or we're gonna go
educate themselves on how to reestablish
some of that privacy yes so this is not
the type of thing that is easy as just
flipping a switch and doing it all at
once because there's a variety of
different methods and it really comes
down to do you want to stay on the
existing network and try to improve the
privacy of your UT expose your bitcoins
on on that network are you willing to
pay a small exchange Fedor exchange to a
more privacy oriented coin and move some
money around there it I think it
basically comes down to how much time
are you willing to put into it how much
in fees are you willing to put into it
I've played around with for example
trying to be a market maker on join
market to actually get paid to mix coins
and unfortunately I barely broke even
with like paying for the transaction of
fees but that is one way that you can do
it that will not cost you much money the
the problem in general that I have with
the various techniques that you need to
improve privacy is that you have to take
your coins out of cold storage if you're
doing mixing you need to put them into
some sort of mixing software like join
mark
wasabi or samurai dojo and those coins
need to be hot they need to be on an
internet-connected device potentially
for days depending on how many rounds of
mixing you're doing so you should if you
have a large amount of money you should
only be doing a little bit of it at a
time and then moving those funds off to
a new wallet which is your your cleanly
fresh coins otherwise you can also you
know go out and try to find one of those
non AML kyc like atomic swap exchanges
exchange your Bitcoin a little bit of at
a time for something like monaro z cash
whatever possibly move it around a
little bit on there and then maybe
eventually you also want to atomic swap
it back but ultimately what you're
trying to do is you're trying to break
those links and it's hard to do that if
you're not technically sophisticated
will that change over time I certainly
hope so
especially with like the next major
upgrade that we're gonna be getting when
we see snore signatures which will
essentially allow for signature
aggregation to happen that will
drastically improve the privacy
attributes of the coin mixers and
actually another thing which I'm I'm
still not quite sure about but for
example there is the liquid side chain
and it has a feature called confidential
transactions and it seems to me like
someone should build a mixer on liquid
that is a confidential transaction mixer
so I don't know why anyone wouldn't do
that maybe we just need a properly
incentivized people three questions to
end it for you what would have to happen
for you to change your mind on Bitcoin
like what is the one or two things that
could occur where you would throw your
hands up and say this isn't going to
play out how I thought or I
no longer believe in Bitcoin hmm that is
tough I mean there are scenarios where
you know if if enough like government
resources were put into it to try to
like track down everyone who is using
Bitcoin you know perhaps by putting
pressure on all the exchanges you know
if if it was outright banned that would
certainly turn most people off to it I
think it would still continue to exist
it would still operate but probably at a
much lower price because the size of the
network would shrink and it would it
would be you know a completely different
adversarial situation especially for me
because I'm well known and even though I
have a great level of privacy like
government could find me if they really
wanted to otherwise I think it's it's
unlikely that there would be a
catastrophic event that was not
recoverable from like even though there
are many potentially catastrophic events
like you know quantum computing or
breaking of important cryptographic
primitives like those things would most
likely be catastrophic for many other
systems that are much larger than
Bitcoin and so that would be more of a
like worldwide global catastrophe type
of issue of people having bigger
problems to worry about but other than
that like I really I continue to think
that the most likely way for Bitcoin to
die is through apathy and you know if it
stagnates for years on end and you know
people stop contributing to it stop
trying to make it better that's when it
becomes a lot less interesting is that
if I I look at this thing as you know
the open source collaborative project
for money then the most important thing
that we can continue to do is to
continue to improve it so that it
becomes better and better option than
the existing fiat system let's hope we
never see any of those things
[Laughter]
what's the most important book you've
ever read oh I mean we have a few that
are required reading at Casa and one of
them is the sovereign individual and I
continue to think that it's quite
prescient and I I see it happening in
the news you know all the time where it
seems like we're in the days right now
where you basically have to be a
billionaire to be a sovereign individual
and have you know the nation state level
sway you know you're at the point where
you can negotiate with nation-states
essentially on a fairly level playing
field but I I do continue to believe
that technology and you know the power
that cryptography gives to people will
continue to lower that bar that would be
a fantastic world to live in I really
really hope you're right their last
question before you get to ask me one to
finish up aliens believer or
non-believer oh yeah I mean it's
statistically practically guaranteed why
well you know it's hard to even hold the
numbers in your head but the the sheer
number of possibilities and and number
of other ecosystems out there that are
similar to ours and thus likely have
life it's just you know with if it's
kind of like mining right is if you try
enough times eventually you'll find that
impossible number to find so I think
you'll find the impossibly right mixture
of chemicals and other elements required
to create life it's scared of thinking
about how big the universe is just for
you know right like and then you get
into other galaxies and kind of the
Infinity type stuff and it's just like
Jesus what that like I don't know it
makes your stomach drop sometimes I
think about
what um what one question do you have
for me to to finish this up uh good
question
so am i correct is your is your
background in marketing no growth yeah
close enough for sure I I ran a couple
of growth teams at UH at Facebook and
snapchat okay
so would you would you say that you're
applying your same type of growth
mindset to Bitcoin to some degree I
would say so two things that I think are
true one
the beauty of money is it's one of the
most viral products in the world right
and if I want to send somebody Bitcoin I
pull them into the network if they're
not already there right and so that ends
up being a very similar tactic to what a
lot of companies try to create with
virality money just inherently has that
and then to is education is always a big
thing awareness is a big thing right and
there's no bigger awareness or education
campaign than what's going on right now
in the macro Empire right I mean look
you know I love the saying of like the
Federal Reserve's running a two trillion
dollar marketing campaign for Bitcoin
right and so I think a lot of that stuff
looks very similar to how a company
would set up marketing and virality
referrals all that kind of stuff
obviously but it's a decentralized
system that no ease you know kind of
coordinating resources to do that the
second piece of it is that I really
think about the growth things that we
did and how can I individually
participate and one of those things is
around pulling people from other
communities or audiences into Bitcoin
right and so one of the things I did
about maybe six months ago or so I
decided hey I'm gonna change the name on
a lot of what I was doing to be less
Bitcoin or
specific and do more of like I want to
talk to interesting people I want to
write about things other than just
Bitcoin and there was questions in the
beginning of like hey are you like
abandoning Bitcoin or like do you do not
believe in it anymore
it says no actually the exact opposite
like I believe in it more today than I
ever have but I also know that if I was
to take the podcast for example if I was
to approach somebody and say do you want
to come on my crypto podcast there's a
lot of people who say yes but there's
even more people who would say no if
instead I say hey do you want to come on
this podcast that has a bunch of other
smart successful people that you admire
and one of the questions maybe about
Bitcoin not as big of a deal right
they're much more open to that so that's
been interesting and the other thing is
I'm unlike the investing side that
entire business like we've always looked
at it as where's the intersection of
like traditional technology
infrastructure and this world right so
obviously we've got a pretty significant
position in Bitcoin itself in the funds
but also like what are all the things
that need to be built in and around to
make this viable right and I think that
there's a lot of opportunities there and
so it's you're kind of providing growth
with capital but ultimately you know
every one of our founders like they're
doing the hard work all right it's a you
know that they're the ones who actually
solve the technical problems they're the
ones you have to recruit and retain
employees they're the ones who have to
actually scale the businesses get
contracts signed kind of do all that
stuff and you know look some of it is
it's gonna be hard no matter what
industry you're operating in as an
entrepreneur but some of this stuff is
very kind of specific whether it's
regulatory or otherwise that just makes
it harder in this space I think so final
related question since I believe you're
the originator or at least popularized
the meme of the virus is spreading is
Bitcoin the virus or is it the vaccine
so I don't actually remember why I
originally tweeted that and I think it
was kind of like a throwaway comment at
first for whatever reason why people
like latched on to it sounds like yeah
like feedback loop cool I'll tweet that
again right and the next you know I
tweeted
bunch of times for obvious reasons that
race has been retired from time being I
I was recently asked do I think it has
to be retired forever or can it make a
comeback probably retired forever at
least for the foreseeable future but but
I think that you know I didn't know this
is Marco sanatoria she told me this in
the early days of Bitcoin like 2011 to
13
there was this common around like a mind
virus right so when I when I first heard
sing and I was thinking more like fire
allottee right kind of the way virus
spreads he said that actually people
didn't use the terminology mind virus
which I thought was pretty applicable
but that's how kind of like offensively
it spreads through the world I think to
your point like when you look at it as a
solution it's definitely the vaccine
right and it can be both it can be
everything yeah and I think that's part
of like people who don't haven't spent a
lot of time thinking about this they're
kind of like what do you guys mean it
could be everything like you know how
come you can apply Bitcoin to all things
and Marty bent has a great way of
putting it he's like look if you fixed
the money you can fix the world right
now I just think like that phrase really
explains a lot of why it's so important
to the global economy but also to kind
of everybody's individual lives and
lifestyles and so it's a it's a pretty
important you know thing to work on I
think people like yourself and others
who you know are actually technically
helping build it I always say like
you're the most important people out
there and also probably if bitcoin was
to fail I actually go with like somehow
it was self-inflicted wound like
something gets pushed or there's some
issue whatever I don't think there's a
high likelihood of it happening but to
me like that's actually the the most
likely thing because I generally think
bit corners are gonna solve the problems
that they're presented with right kind
of keep going where where can we send
people where do you want to send them
either to find you online or learn more
about Casa yeah so casa very easy just
keys dot
Casa keys CA si will take you to our
site with all of our security related
material and as for myself my site is
lop dotnet and you can find my Twitter
my articles I've written and all of my
550 or so educational resource links I
will give you a major major vote of
approval in that your or Thea slop
dotnet slash Bitcoin yeah I send people
there all the time it is by far the most
robust resource page I think on the
Internet so Bitcoin dot page will take
you directly there if that's easier for
people to remember whatever you're doing
keep updating that because that uh when
people say how do I learn about Bitcoin
I send them there and I'm always scared
like I'm gonna overwhelm them but I just
warn the michaelis and just work your
way through these links and and you'll
be an expert in no time start at the top
absolutely Melissa James I really
appreciate you doing this will link to a
cost I think people should go and check
it out and for everybody I just
appreciate all the the work that you've
done because you are one of the most
important people helping build build
this future world that we all want my
pleasure I'm here to help happy having